[Laughter]
[Music]
today's topic the cut
ooh why don't you smell each other oh
smell each other yeah i'm smelling
are we how close to each other do you
feel my breath
do you feel you feel my
you feel my breath you feel it
do you feel it now do you feel that get
closer to the camera
you feel my breath now you feel that
you're careful don't block it don't blow
on the legs [ __ ] because it might
actually feel it
don't block that
[Laughter]
my breath i i felt a bit of uh dr phil
in him oh yeah
uh do you feel do you feel my breath do
you feel it
because the thing that happens is that
you have to actually
feel my breath are we close enough to
each other is it
anyways you have to cry you have to feel
the breath of each other
in order to create a real connection all
right that's actually really good
all right let's start are you guys ready
to see each other i'm excited for this
hello hi you're cute hey
yeah i'm sorry very cute great smile
thank you yeah
can we have a drink now can we like yeah
yeah you guys have a shot together
okay we're having tequila do this
which one of us do you think is more
attractive
just answer because at this point if you
don't answer we know what you think
if you do answer we know you're lying
so just answer truthfully because we
know it's okay
it's okay to feel like you look better
than the other one i clearly look better
than abba it's cool right
yeah that's fine see even though you
know
judging by the dms hey man
i don't know no but judging by the dm
that that statement
hey my [ __ ] you put in some
i'm giving you a compliment just take it
yeah i took it yeah you don't have to
take me put me down i'm not putting you
down
i'm saying you're doing great without
putting effort that's just natural
uh-huh yeah yeah whatever [ __ ]
it sounds like you was putting no you
that's just natural okay judging by all
right if you want to hurt my feelings
you didn't even
want to hurt my feelings you don't even
have anything accomplished
all right moving on he's salty why are
you salty i know you're not adding you
don't like this
chad who do you think is more attractive
her obviously
i don't think i'm attractive
i'm just saying that now
i like this guy chad looked today that's
like
no no no no no don't just say that no no
you don't like this no yeah dead ass and
he said it with no hesitation yes that's
what i do you're just saying that
ideally how often should a couple have
sex
they should probably negotiate that i'm
like if one really likes sex maybe you
gotta like
fulfill that person more it was in my
eyes i'd say daily
gotta do it i think daley's not the
worst thing not the worst
not the worst what is your type
am i your type yeah i would say i mean
taller you're almost there taller than
6'3 huh
does it help i tell you i can dunk does
that help
this nigga's taking the piss does it
help if i say that you know i could dunk
[Music]
she thinks she's way more interesting
than she actually is and he's just like
nah
but it's interesting to watch i like
this can you show me your tinder grinder
bumble profile right now grinder yeah
grinder's
um my favorite of all apps
i'm like tinder yeah it's like that
[Music]
yo i like it what's his name chad
chad if you listen to this
oh man yes my dude you know there's a
moment where he says grinder is my
favorite and she goes
oh is that like tinder in his face
[Music]
are you yeah it's exactly are you dumb
oh my god chad is the dude chad hey man
he might he might have gotten rejected
but she's taking this l but you know you
just
this just he's been rejected and he
knows how to deal with let me tell you
chad
this doesn't fade i can assure you chad
cleans up yes but he did
because this does he may not look like a
champion but he lives like a chat
but um a lot more men on it
way more
okay see she likes my profile
that means that's good things right
karaoke
yeah singer huge let's hear it say it
ain't so
i will not go turn the lights off carry
me home
do you think karaoke then you got to go
too i no i don't
whoa what a setup i'm not for sure
you're like karaoke i'm like boom
yo chad is the dude chad is the dude
chad is that dude that's funny what
sound do you make when you're having sex
can you make it right now please
sometimes i like stallion up and like
before i get in there i could do like a
like a horse nay like yeah
[Laughter]
she's trolling her she can't tell she
can't tell
and so he says like is she gonna clue oh
man
is there anything yo
[Music]
over her head finish this line my
favorite genre of porn is
i mean it's something okay i'll just
pour it up yeah
one of those things yeah you can't just
no
what is my least attractive feature
right now
a shirt really
shirt pretty bad pretty bad
i'm sorry that's okay [ __ ] who came
with regular jeans and a long-sleeve
shirt
okay there's bones on it
the air in there those are flowers
that's a boat
what would you call that a lily maybe
[Laughter]
that is awesome i don't know you're
talking about
i dare you to kiss me on the lips or
take a shot
that's the last card that is the lip
what kind of magicians are up here i
we were watching the cards the entire
time how did you guys do that
wait yeah you guys don't want to
[Music]
she's glaring at your cameraman it can
be any kind of kiss it could be a quick
pack
on the lips on the cheek lips
i don't kiss on the first date either
unless it's grinder always kiss on the
first date
[Music]
chad is the dude that's how you handle
rejection chad is the dude that's how
you handle rejection either walk away
or if you're forced to be there just be
casual just have some fun with him just
have a few laughs
this is what a healthy rejection looks
like
even though the girl she really took the
l in this because she came out as a
person with no personality
um that's how you take rejection i was
really impressed actually he's pretty
good i'm gonna give that a like
yeah yeah chad you're that dude
yeah the art of being able to take
rejection is super important how well
someone takes a rejection
means everything but it's like i think
you have to take your toll of rejection
to be like you know what
yeah and you're gonna increase your
success rate
you're gonna increase your success rate
by having a [ __ ] attitude about it
all right you know what [ __ ] it this
ain't a thing i ain't got nothing to
lose
i don't care i don't care let's just go
what's up
man not be arrogant about it this is the
difference
right there's a difference between
americans and that but it should be like
yeah it could be this
when you're too clingy and you put all
your like you're like oh you're the one
you know the girl that had no hair the
guy looked like oh my god you're so
beautiful even without the hair yeah i
mean you're
just like relax dude yep
how do you think we're like jackson you
would be surprised how many times i've
heard no
and then later heard yes and i'm not
talking about this
what's your rule i'm talking about maybe
a month for now maybe a year after maybe
five years after how you leave a
situation
will determine whether or not there's
odds of you percent potentially coming
back to it
years later breath she says no take your
stuff
and bounce or you know end the date
amicably
have a couple more talks about it you
know and then leaf but
if you get rejected man don't be butt
hurt about it you'll be
shocked you'll be surprised how many
times
i've heard no and then weeks years
months later
say hey what are you up to and then all
of a sudden the door's open
because when you get rejected sometimes
it's not even about you sometimes it's
just circumstances
maybe the girl is out of a relationship
she's not ready maybe the girl is just
not feeling that day because she's on
her period or she's hormone
maybe it's because family member you
don't know
when you take an l walk away from it
clean and this is not even a
a relationship thing job thing too if
you get rejected from a job
do you think there's any option for you
to get rehired there if on the exit of
your failed interview you go
[ __ ] everybody you're a [ __ ] you're
never going to get hired there and
you'll probably never get hired with
their partners
walk away from any rejection in life
as amicably as possible
take it on the chin bruh you took the l
walk away
maybe you'll turn into a w later but for
now just hold your l
okay yeah that's really okay yeah it's
part of life
you're going to get rejected yup yup yup
depending on your status better because
depending on your status depending on
your looks some people are going to be
less rejected some people are never
going to see rejection right
but prepare better you're prepared for
rejection yeah and i'm telling you this
can help you with relationships
and your professional life everything
learn to get told
no okay
all right that's it for today's video
tell us what you guys think
i just need to hold myself because i was
thinking about all the rejections i ever
had
i just walked home and i'm just like
[Laughter]
i don't know i just kept talking about
relationship but i just kept feeling my
arm
you need to hold yourself
[Music]